[Music]
the views and opinions expressed on this
program are those of the guests
appearing on the program
and do not necessarily reflect the views
and opinions of 8 news now or next our
media group
the end is in sight nevada we can do
this
tonight on politics now in the home
stretch new vaccine guidelines one year
after the pandemic shut our valley down
plus
i'm here to thank you on behalf of the
president myself
and our country for what you all are
doing
vice president kamala harris visits las
vegas to rally health care workers
and pitch the biden administration's
covert relief plan
a lot of them they ignore the hype
nevada police unions weigh in on several
reform bills being considered in the
nevada legislature
from eight news now this is politics now
this is affecting the lives of our
citizens
people are dying it's incumbent upon the
citizens of this state
to take this seriously that is governor
steve sisilak
one year ago this week shutting nevada
down and telling all of us to stay home
it was the start of the pandemic the las
vegas strip was closed it was eerily
quiet
dark for the first time since the jfk
assassination in 1963.
well this kicked off our one-year roller
coaster with covid covid19
fast forward now to today more nevadans
are getting the vaccine
our economy is slowly returning to
normal this week governor assisilek
announced
all nevadans aged 16 and older with an
underlying health condition can get the
vaccine starting on monday
on april 5th everybody in the state
health condition or no
16 and older is eligible nevada is now
getting nearly 65 000 doses of the
vaccine every week from the federal
government
with more shipments coming soon the
governor says he's hopeful for the
future
nevada will be the safest place to have
a convention
or come and visit it'll be safe for the
tourists
and business travelers it will be safe
for employees
and will be safe for their families
still governor sysolak is urging
everyone to be patient with vaccines
the actual availability of vaccine
appointments is going to depend on the
allocation of doses from the federal
government
this week kamala harris the vice
president made her first visit to las
vegas since she
got her new job her stop in the valley
was part of a tour touting the biden
administration's coveted relief efforts
and the i-team's david charns is here to
tell us about the visit david
well john the president and vice
president are essentially going around
the country
selling that huge american rescue plan
that giant 1.9 trillion dollar spending
package that includes
those stimulus checks for most of us the
vice president starting her visit right
here in las vegas with a stop at a unlv
vaccination
vaccination
site i'm here to thank you
on behalf of the president myself and
our country
for what you all are doing i know it
takes a lot out of you
we got light at the end of the tunnel
you've got the most amazing governor we
can imagine
she chatted with nursing and med
students there and thanked them all for
their work
she and her husband also visited the
culinary academy of las vegas
where the community food assistance
program has donated nearly 13 million
pounds of food just during the pandemic
alone
the vice president speaking about how
the rescue plan benefits students and
union members
including those extended unemployment
benefits through september
and the child tax credit of three
thousand dollars
president biden you'll remember a while
back he said help is on the way
and then he signed that american rescue
plan so i would say
help is here help is here
help is here and as the congressman said
there are a number of things that it
does
and so i'm here to also make sure we get
the word out
now part of that massive plan includes
four billion dollars coming right to the
state of nevada
nearly 3 billion of that is going to
cover the cost of our state budget which
itself
is about 4 billion a year republican
assemblyman tom roberts says he and his
colleagues
now need to be mindful about how they're
going to spend it
the amount of money that we're getting
this time is probably more than enough
money which is why i believe
that we should shore up our rainy day
fund in case something like this happens
again we have a fourth wave or whatever
and it impacts tourism and
we shouldn't just continue to count on
the federal government to bail us out
and the national republican party
telling us this in quotes
this massive 1.9 trillion dollar
stimulus bill has very little to do with
covert relief
and amounts to nothing more than a
progressive wish list now harris says
the plan will bring 40 thousand children
right here in nevada out of poverty
her visit comes as most businesses are
now at that 50 percent capacity mark
and as the clark kennedy school district
gets more than 800 million dollars as
part of all this new funding john all
right david thank you very much
now to carson city and the legislative
session more police reform bills are
being introduced
and one from the nevada attorney
general's office allows that office to
investigate local police agencies
is assembly bill 58 and it asks for the
ability to do a pattern or practice
investigation to see if an officer's
misconduct is
a one-off or if it is a larger
deficiency in training and culture
within that department
assembly speaker jason fryerson
introduced assembly bill 282
that requires implicit bias training for
judges and any court employees who
interact with the public
a separate bill earlier this session
requires the same thing for law
enforcement
and then there is senate bill 236 it was
introduced by democratic state senator
dallas harris
it includes some sweeping change
proposals it would require police
agencies to establish an early warning
system to detect bias or problematic
behavior in officers
new officers would need at least an
associate's degree or two years of
military service to join the force
the bill also limits some of the current
legal protections for officers if
they're sued for something they have
done while on the job
those are three of dozens of bills that
deal with either law enforcement or
criminal justice
so how does nevada law enforcement feel
about some of these potential changes
david charns interviewed rich mccann he
is executive director of the nevada
association of public safety officers
and david's first question is it hard to
be a police officer in 2021
well some would say yes some would say
no depending upon your perspective
there's a lot of police officers out
there that go about their jobs each and
every day in a very
in a very dignified very professional
very humble way
to a lot of them they ignore the hype
they ignore all the problems that are
being generated around the country
um and they do their job and to them
they're saying listen
it's no different now than it was before
but for others
they have a different mindset and
they're entitled to that mindset
because there is an attack there's an
attack upon law enforcement by a lot of
different factions
what are the things that you're watching
and what are some of the things that
you're either
uh happy that could become law maybe
or uh concerns that could become
law so it is a slow going process but
there are issues that we are looking at
that have that that that 64 000 term do
it that everybody kind of gets on
no knock warrants we dealt with that for
a long time yesterday because that's one
of the ag's bills
patterns and practices or patterns or
practices of conduct
that may lead to discriminatory conduct
by an agency a police agency law
enforcement agency
how do we identify that what's the ag's
involvement
when something's been brought to their
attention that something is a repeated
pattern
or practice in a law enforcement agency
that should be stopped
what's the ag's uh jurisdiction to do
something about it and what if it
happens to be a state agency
that is under scrutiny well that state
agency's lawyer happens to be the ag
so should it be the ag be investigating
itself
these are all great questions and again
we had some pretty robust conversation
about it for seven or eight hours
yesterday
and we will continue to have more uh
that's a good thing
and then of course there's the other
issues of training a lot of these bills
that we
are seeing and we'll see they will have
a component of them of training
you just can't tell cops you know change
your stripes overnight
how do you in your position
advocate for
or against these proposals that are
basically
changing how one does their job well
yesterday was a
good example on for example the no knock
warrants this may
hit a little bit upon which your
question is getting rid of no knock
warrants nope no more no knock words is
that the only thing we're deciding to do
well that means it's a one-word bill yes
or no well there's obviously much more
to it than that
we talked in great great uh just got a
great
time consumption about well who can
request
a no knock warrant admittedly
our law enforcement officers who were
represented at that meeting yesterday
across the board said
there that they can count on one hand
over a long career the number of times
in a no-knock warrant has been used by
their agency
so it's not as prevalent as people think
it is
every case is not brianna taylor
that's nothing to say anything about
brianna taylor god love that situation
uh but not every case is that but this
was born
out of as a result of that we know that
let's
call it what it is this situation a lot
of our situations were born out of
police conduct that may have gone awry
or at least allegedly did
even if ultimately the proof is that it
did not
so in verona taylor's case and the no
not warrant concern that the world now
has
they didn't know what they were before
but now they are you just don't say yay
or nay well
who is qualified to request a no knock
warrant
more importantly what standards must be
met before a judge remember it's a
warrant
i don't issue a warrant you don't issue
a warrant judges issue warrants
based upon probable cause maybe we need
to
make those standards that a judge looks
at more stringent
so that's part of the discussion i'll
point out mccann's union represents
mostly state law enforcement officers
and other
jurisdictions like henderson police not
metro police though that's a different
union
now the no knock warrant bill that
mccann mentioned that senate bill 50 did
pass its senate committee this week
mccann believes some lawmakers are
taking high profile national events to
create
laws to make sure something doesn't
happen here as he referenced
however mccann adds like any job those
laws does do not mean
you won't have one bad employee we will
follow the bills as they move forward
so far in fact more than 600 bills have
been introduced in total up in carson
city here are the deadlines for
lawmakers to try and get them passed
and those deadlines have been moved back
several times however monday is the
deadline for lawmakers to introduce
bills
on march 30th the money committees
that's senate finance assembly ways and
means
they begin to close budgets for state
agencies april
9th is the deadline for bills to get out
of their first committee unless they've
been exempted
this is a deadline that typically kills
a lot of proposals april 20th is the
deadline for bills to make it out of
their house of origin
this week assembly speaker jason
fryerson aside from the measures
happening in carson city
he announced he has prostate cancer
however fryerson adds he is recovering
comfortably
fyerson had outpatient surgery for the
cancer on wednesday he says he feels
good
and he expects to be back at the
legislature on monday
fryerson says that the cancer was
detected early through regular checkups
governor steve sisolak signed a bill
this week allowing lobbyists to register
for the session
assembly bill 110 allows them to start
lobbying by changing language
that requires them to be physically
present in the building
lobbyists will still have to register
the changes came after groups of
lobbyists filed a lawsuit
and they called on the legislature to
let them in of course there were the
coronavirus restrictions there
coming up next on politics now reminding
students they have
help coming up the solutions being
presented to help stop a spike in
teenage
suicides during the pandemic and crisis
at the border what steps are being taken
to deal with a massive influx of
migrants
welcome back to politics now
nevada's secretary of state's office
says it has started looking through
election complaints from the state's
republican party
gop chairman michael mcdonald first
claimed there were nearly 123 thousand
unique complaints however the secretary
of state's office says
4 000 were filed in all of them by
mcdonald
staff say that several are already under
investigation by law enforcement
the challenges of this past year as we
know have taken a toll on our children
and their mental health clark county
school district says in fact 23 students
have taken their own lives in the past
year the year before
the number was nine oracle mana was at a
forum this week to address the issue of
student suicides it's been very
difficult for her
karina singer says her 8th grade
daughter selma has had a tough time
since distance learning
began she's just very lonely she said
very
sad she pretty much stays in her room
all day and doesn't really do anything
karina says thankfully selma doesn't
have any suicidal thoughts but suicide
among clark county students
is a concern the district saying 23
students have died by suicide since
march
2020. suicide is not a choice mental
health experts joining ccsd leaders
monday night to discuss how to tackle
the issue
one way is through the columbia protocol
a series of simple but pointed questions
to assess someone's risk of suicide
the columbia protocol is the ultimate
see something say something
to help prevent suicide state leaders
agree having the right tools is key
to be able to detect and intervene when
an individual is suffering
is really the best way to go so with
ccsd implementing the columbia protocol
are you working on providing teachers
these sheets we're going to start
looking at the next steps is how to
how do we get those out through our
schools and not just in our in our
classrooms in our schools but
in our departments one parent who lost
his son to suicide also stressing the
importance of openness
you make it okay to talk about it for
and mainly if you're
having one of the suicide days that's
something karina plans to do
i'm definitely going to continue the
conversation orco mana 8 news now
if you or someone you know is struggling
you can call the number on your screen
it is the national suicide prevention
lifeline
1-800-2738
advocates are also pushing for more
legislative reform when it comes to
addressing mental health among students
more counselors in particular
ccsd is dealing with another issue right
now student enrollment it has dropped
during distance learning
data shows a decline in all student
groups who live in las vegas but
especially students who identify as
white at least ten thousand fewer
students enrolled this school year
compared to before the pandemic
ccsd associate superintendent lorna
james cervantes presented these numbers
wednesday at the las vegas city council
meeting
she says a lot of students that live in
the summerlin and southern highlands
neighborhoods
enrolled in private or parochial schools
we're offering
full in-person learning at the beginning
of the year
however many of those parents are
already beginning to call and say okay
as soon as you're back
we're coming back now also
we were told by ccsd there other
students moved out of state
after their family lost their jobs
another reason why enrollment went down
next on politics now migrants at the
border how the biden administration says
it is dealing with the biggest
influx of people trying to get into the
u.s in 20 years
you're watching politics now
number of migrants arriving at the
southern u.s border is growing
fema is now moving unaccompanied
children to the dallas convention center
because the border facilities are just
too
crowded the u.s is on track to see more
people at the southwest border than it
has in the past 20 years
border patrol says unaccompanied minors
are not being turned away however
single adults and families are
republicans blame the bidet
administration and its rollback of
former president trump's border policies
main problem at the border right now is
that the biden administration doesn't
want to enforce
america's immigration laws and it it's
choosing not
to stop the flow of illegal immigration
we recognize this is a big problem the
last administration
left us a dismantled and unworkable
system
and like any other problem we are going
to do everything we can
to solve it joining us to talk about the
big influx of
undocumented immigrants right now at the
southern u.s border our washington dc
correspondent alexander limon joining us
now
alex let's talk about republican
lawmakers they're saying this is a
crisis the border not secure right now
how is the bidet administration
responding to their criticisms and the
crisis in general
republican lawmakers have been focusing
a lot on the situation playing out on
the u.s mexico border as you said
calling it a crisis and questioning
whether the border is in fact secure
and blaming biden directly for this huge
influx of migrants that we're seeing
saying that because he halted
construction of the border wall that
that sends a message to
migrants to come to the united states
because the border is wide open
now obviously the biden administration
is pushing back on that saying just
because we're not building a border
barrier doesn't mean that the border is
open
and in fact we heard the president
directly counter that in
an interview earlier this week telling
migrants sending that message directly
to them saying
you know don't come here right now we've
also uh
seen the secretary of dhs alejandro
mallierkas testified before congress
this week
and he sort of tiptoed around calling it
a crisis not actually using that word
but admitting that the situation
is very difficult and that we are seeing
record numbers of migrants show up at
the border
at the same time though we've also heard
from the border officials who are
actually
you know there on the ground along the
border saying
yes this is a huge influx we're seeing a
lot of undocumented
children arriving alone at the border as
well so that's a huge concern
but they say that it's a really large
number of people compared to this time
last year but the numbers actually
started to rise a little at the end of
2020 that's when we started to see the
uptick
so it's tied to to a few different
things not only the election but
potentially also
the pandemic and all of the lockdowns
that we really saw
around the world you know during the
summer aside from the semantics what is
the white house doing to try and deal
with the issue whether they call it a
crisis or not
they are expelling migrants uh who don't
qualify for asylum
and having them leave the united states
so they're not just accepting everyone
but they are also at the same time
increasing the holding capacity
at different types of dhs facilities for
those people who are seeking asylum who
may qualify we heard
we've heard from different
administration officials saying that
they're trying to work to make the
asylum system
work in a faster and fairer way but
that's obviously going to take some time
because
obviously for years now there's been
this huge backlog of hundreds of
thousands of immigration cases so that's
something that they're working toward
but it'll be interesting to
see how quickly that can actually happen
you know expediting these cases through
the system
and that was alexander limon from
washington d.c
nevada democratic senator catherine
cortez masto was reintroducing two
pieces of legislation
to try and address housing
discrimination one law would require
large banks and credit unions that
provide mortgages to make their
information public
that would give the government data to
try and keep them accountable
it's already being collected it's just
not being shared
with government agencies and advocates
who want to protect and guard against
discrimination so my
my legislation actually allows for that
information that data to be shared again
if passed one law would fund a
nationwide fair housing plan
senator cortez masto says they would
also reinstate
protections to make sure lenders are
held accountable if they discriminate
next on politics now ambassador dina
titus
coming up the country nevada's
congresswoman might soon be an envoy too
you're watching politics now
nevada congresswoman dina titus says
she's interested in an
ambassadorship to greece this is a story
first reported by the new york times and
confirmed by
our i-team titus was the first prominent
nevada politician to endorse joe biden
during his presidential campaign
if she were picked there would be a
special election for her seat
congressional district one is a very
heavy democratic district here in nevada
and it is likely the party would keep
that seat
here's what we are watching coming up
this week we are keeping an eye on some
last
minute bills up at the legislative
session the deadline for lawmakers to
submit
bills up in carson city has been
extended twice already
the deadline now is monday and we are
expecting a flurry of last-minute
legislation we will keep an eye on that
and hopefully you will as well
thank you for watching politics now stay
up to date online 8newsnow.com
we'll see you right back here next week